[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est un immense violoniste
l'un des plus grands au monde quand il
était petit son professeur a annoncé à
ses parents qu'il n'étaient pas musicien
qu'il avait l'oreille absolue comprenez
bien qu'il est capable entre autres de
reconnaître une note un son comme ça
simplement juste en l'écoutant un don
une passion des répétitions quotidiennes
et un entourage compréhensif tout cela
lui a permis d'avoir une carrière hors
norme plus de 100 concerts par an
direction d'orchestre création de
festival production d'album aujourd'hui
il joue il dirige il programme il fait
vivre la musique classique à travers le
monde il la fait partager il la pense
mon appréhension de la musique a changé
dit-il j'ai moins de complexe je suis
plus à même d'ouvrir les vannes mais
alors est-il arrivé au sommet de son art
a-t-il l'impression de pouvoir encore
progresser que lui faudrait-il pour être
encore meilleur quelle marche a-t-il
encore envie de gravir posons-lui toutes
ces questions bienvenue dans un monde à
regard bienvenue Renault capuon merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici au
D Tournon au Sénat est-ce que à votre
niveau on peut encore être l'élève de
quelqu'un est-ce qu'on a encore des
petits accros à corriger toujours
d'abord je pense que le jour où on pense
qu'on est arrivé ou qu'on a plus rien à
apprendre il faut tout de suite ranger
l'instrument et et partir s'isoler
quelque part je pense que le le le but
même d'être un un musicien c'est d'abord
d'être un artisan moi je me considère
comme un artisan avant d'être un artiste
bien sûr que je suis artiste mais on
passe notre temps à chercher à essayer
d'être meilleur à à peaufiner un détail
donc oui j'apprends au contact de chef
d'orchestre j'apprends énormément au
contact d'autres collègues musiciens et
aussi au contact des jeunes ce qui est
assez paradoxal h le fait d'igner moiême
depuis 2014 à Lausanne me donne la
possibilité en apprenant aux jeunes
musiciens de réapprendre moi-même et
donc c'est un cycle permanent et ce qui
fait qu'en fait on se découvre des
problèmes pas des problèmes et des
défauts des choses au fur à mesure
qu'onon est dans j'ai évoqué cette idée
d'oreille absolue qu'est-ce que c'est
précisément je l'ai défin rapidement
mais c'est quelque chose qui vous a
donné de l'avance par rapport aux autres
je sais pas j'ai des des copains qui ont
pas l' absolu qui sont des merveilleux
musicien l'oreil absolu c'est de
reconnaître si vous jouez une note au
piano on peut reconnaître un L un dos
peut-être que ça ça avantage un tout
petit peu au début j'avais 4 ans ça m'a
peut-être donné peut-être un peu plus de
de d'énergie inconsciente mais je crois
pas que ça ça change la nature même du
musicien il faut paraît-il en tout cas
pour bien jouer du violon en jouer tous
les jours est-ce que c'est votre cas
est-ce que vous jouez encore tous les
jours combien d'heures par jour est-ce
que c'est toujours un plaisir de jouer
est-ce que aussi c'est parfois une
corvée non là j'ai la chance d'avoir eu
toujours envie de jouer je crois que
c'est la clé c'est le moteur c'est
l'envie euh beaucoup travailler oui tous
les jours oui
entre 12 et et 25 ans j'ai travaillé 7 à
8 he par jour donc oui c'est beaucoup
sans beaucoup de vacances et cetera mais
c'était une volonté personnelle
aujourd'hui il y a il y a bien des jours
où je ne joue pas et c'est très
nécessaire parce qu'il faut aussi
d'abord ça ça décrasse ça permet de
faire comme un détox et on se sent mieux
là j'ai donné un concert hier et j' 48
heur avant j'étais dans mon festival
j'avais pas pu travailler vraiment mon
violon de façon quotidienne vous étiez
rouillé au contraire non j'étais
totalement si vous voulez si vous
arrêtez de semaines là il faut repasser
un petit peu de temps mais quand on
s'arrête deux ou TR jours il y a aucun
problème et je dis même à mes élèves
quand ils partent en vacances l'été
prenez sur les 5 semaines prenez de
toute façon de semaines où vous ne
touchez pas d'instrument parce que c'est
une façon aussi de de revenir plus frais
exactement et de l'aimer à nouveau au
retour le violon est votre passion mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a aussi un
combat chez vous c'est de démocratiser
la musique classique c'est vrai oui
alors c'est pas c'est pas une chose le
mot démocratisé il est il peut être
aussi pris comme une sorte de j'aime pas
le populisme en fait donc ne pas aller
jusqu'au populisme en musique parce que
la musique classique c'est quelque chose
d'universel de beau comme un tableau
peut être partagé par tout le monde une
œuvve de Brams ou de Mozart peut être
aimé par tout le monde donc c'est
simplement peut-être que les générations
d'avant étaient un peu plus compassé un
peu plus on était un peu plus dans un
contre soi et j'aime l'idée que la
musique est pour tout le monde donc
quand j'enregistre comme je viens de
faire ind dis de musique de film c'est
aussi une façon une main tendue en
disant je joue Brams Mozart Schoubert et
de la musique d'aujourd'hui mais je peux
aussi jouer de la musique de film et ça
permet parfois un public de venir à
l'Olympia alors qu'il ne viendrait pas à
la Philharmonie mais est-ce qu'on est on
peut tous être sensible à la musique
classique ou est-ce qu'il faut quand
même une oreille un peu éduquée vous
parliez des tableaux finalement quand on
connaît un peu le contexte d'une œuvre
l'histoire d'un peintre on est quand
même beaucoup plus sensé bien sûr est
queussi pour la musiqueassque estce
qu'on est dans l'émotion je pense que la
différence avec le le le le tableau et
moi-même j'ai j'ai parfois un complexe
quand je vais au musée parce que je me
trouve dans des œuvres incroyables et
j'ai l'impression que je ne comprends
pas donc je comprends très bien le le
spectateur qui va avoir cette peur là au
concert la grande différence c'est que
la musique dans la plupart des cas de
gens qui viennent pour la première fois
vous emmènne et vous procure une émotion
qui est sensorielle vous pouvez me dire
c'est la même chose avec un tableau ça
me semble plus abstrait avec un tableau
si vous n'avez pas la connaissance
intellectuelle euh en tout cas moi je
suis pour emmener des enfants des gens
de toute génération et toute catégorie
sociale au concert mais vous êtes
d'accord que c'est quand même encore un
public averti éduqué hautement éduqué
qui bien écout non non je crois que
vraiment la Philharmonie de Paris a a
montré a prouvé l'inverse je je me
souviens des des des des conversations
enflammées au moment de la construction
de la Philharmonie avec tous les gens
qui disaient mais c'est c'est personne
n'ira là-bas c'est le bout du monde
c'est très loin on peut pas se garer
j'en passe et des meilleurs et
finalement les concerts sont pleins
c'est un succès formidable on voit que
le public avec tous les publics le
public est extrêmement
varié playel qui était la salle avant
pour le classique qui a donc la
Philharmonie a remplacé playel les les
gens étaient plutôt mieux habillés
aujourd'hui vous avez des gens qui sont
costume cravate et la majeure partie des
gens sont habillés de façon totalement
décontractée il y a beaucoup de jeunes
et c'est une réussite totale parce que
ce dont on parle me fait beaucoup penser
à cette scène dans le film intouchable
avec au Marcy et François Cluset on a
vous souriez je suis sûre que vous savez
de quoi je parle il y a cette scène
notamment où François Cluset parle
musique classique parle de sa passion et
auarsy qui lui écoute plutôt du funk est
assez insensible à ce style de musique
il lui dit bah moi Mozart Bram c'est la
musique des assédiques le répondeur des
assédiques on a quand même deux univers
qui se qui ont du mal à se rejoindre oui
alors c'est bien sûr un peu caricatural
même si ça m'arrive parfois quelqu'un
dit ah mais mais vous avez joué un air
je le connais parce que je l'ai vu bon
donc on peut pas échapper à ça et c'est
pas grave euh mais je pense que c'est
pour cette raison aussi que ces gens-là
n'osent pas aller au concert parce
qu'ils ont peur du jugement et moi j'ai
toujours beaucoup d'indulgence quand les
gens applaudissent entre les mouvements
euh j'ai une situation un jour où le
public connaisseur disait chute euh
pendant que les gens applaudissaient
pendant les mouvements d'ord et c'est un
tel point que ça ça montait un peu le le
l'atmosphère dans la salle j'ai pris la
parole à la fin en disant vous savez euh
quand applaudissements ont lieu comme ça
de façon spontanée moi je suis très
heureux parce que ça veut dire qu'il y a
un public qui est nouveau et donc j'ai
envie de dire bienvenue un public
nouveau qui ne connaît pas les
règles ce sont des codes tacites on
applaud des codes oui le code tacite
c'est quand vous avez une UV de quatre
mouvements vous applaudissez pas entre
les mouvement vous a à la fin mais s
sont des gens qui ont été habitués à
écouter des concerts de variété où le
format c'est 3 minutes bah ils
applaudissent quand ça s'arrête et c'est
très logique aussi alors si nous on
réagit de façon et c'est spontané si on
si on réagit n de façon abrupte on peut
être sûr que ces gens ne reviendront
plus jamais au concert donc ça passe par
d'innombrables petits signaux comme ça
qui font que quand même l'interprète est
aussi responsable parmi les disques que
vous avez sortis vous en avez parlé il y
a cinéma album hommage au grand écran
avec des arrangements sur des musiques
de film comme laalist de Schindler
légende d'automne le fabuleux destin
d'Amélie Poulin et au sujet de cet album
vous aviez dit une chose que j'ai trouvé
intéressante il y a 20 ans si l'on
m'avait proposé d'enregistrer un disque
de bande originale de film j'aurais
répondu ah non que va-t-on penser de moi
j'étais extrêmement fermé ma bulle je
l'ai fait éclater au moment où j'ai
rencontré ma femme Laurence Ferrari
vivre avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas
musicien m'a ouvert ça veut dire que au
départ c'est peut-être un monde quand
même un peu fermé où ça l'était ça ne
l'est plus je pense que c'est j'ai
employé une mot de bulle parce que quand
j'ai rencontré mon épouse elle m'a dit
mais en fait ça fait 20 ans que tu vis
dans une bulle parce que j'avais beau
être connecté avec l'extérieur bien sûr
et avec l'actualité j'ai toujours été
passionné de politique par exemple mais
comme je fréquentais à 99 % des musicien
j'étais dans une bulle mais c'est comme
si vous êtes médecin et vous ne voyez
que des médecins et a un moment donné
vous êtes dans une sorte de bulle et le
fait de de ne connaître que des gens qui
ne faisaiit qu'écouter de la musique
classique j'étais effectivement un peu
hermétique à tout le reste et et j'ai
appris à à m'ouvrir beaucoup plus et et
j'ai beaucoup reçu justement des gens de
l'extérieur j'ai beaucoup compris
comment il fonctionnit et et oui je
pense que la musique de film peut être
un un moyen merveilleux pour tendre la
main à des gens qui qui qui ne
connaissent pas forcément la musique
classique de quel film auriez-vous aimé
composer la musique ah peut-être Cinéma
Paradiso parce que la musique de moricon
est absolument incroyable ou par exemple
la musique du mépris de de l rue ou ces
musiques qui qui vous emmènent
instantanément dans un dans un univers
différent vous êtes un peu à part dans
cet univers le journal Le Monde vous a
qualifié un jour de véritable
entrepreneur amateur de politique et de
mondanité il a un agenda de ministrees
une discipline d'athlètes de haut niveau
un carnet d'adresse rempli de noms de
grands patron qui a-t-il dans ce cas
carnet d'adresse est-ce que vous avez
des GR alors c'est c'est un peu
caricatural parce que de dire que je une
vie de mondanité ça c'est vraiment
l'opposé de ce que je suis je me suis
défini tout de suite dans cet entretien
comme un artisan et un artiste il se
trouve il se trouve que par mon métier
je rencontre des gens qui sont des gens
très connus ou des gens très importants
comme des présidents ou des des
voilà et des patrons d'entreprise mais
le but n'est pas de faire des mondanités
le but est de faire toujours fonctionner
la musique c'estd que si je rencontre un
patron d'entreprise mon idée c'est
comment faire pour qu'il s'intéresse à
la musique pour voilà créer des liens
pour qu'au final il investisse parce
qu'on a besoin de
C c'est une sensibilité c'est essayer de
faire en sorte que partout dans dans
notre
monde la société d'aujourd'hui là je
vous parlais tout à l'heure du public
mais ça passe aussi par des des
investisseurs ça passe aussi par des
messenes ça passe par des politiques et
et mon rôle finalement si vous prenez
quelqu'un comme rostropovic ou comme
barenb ou comme minuin ce sont pour moi
des des exemples des phes comme ça qui
qui éclaire qui illumine et qui
rassureine et qui ont fait qui ont joué
ce rôle là euh baren BO et allit parler
à Angela Merkel il a parlé à beaucoup de
politiques il a rencontré le pape à
chaque fois c'était pas pour dire j'ai
rencontré telle personne mais c'était
pour s'investir et chaque fois que j'ai
l'occasion ou la possibilité de
rencontrer des gens de cette cette
notoriété ou de cette importance c'est
toujours pour que la musique euh puisse
grandir et et je pense que c'est c'est
important d'avoir des gens comme nous h
alors vous êtes né un 27 janvier comme
Mozard on vous le dit souvent comme oui
sauf que je réponds toujours que lui
n'est pas au courant donc ça change pas
grandchose en tout cas c'est comme si
votre destin de musicien était était
écrit et pourtant non aucun musicien
professionnel dans votre famille votre
père qui travaille dans l'administration
des douanes et votre mère qui s'occupe
de ses trois enfants apprennent à aimer
la musique classique en allant au
festival des arcs pas loin de chez vous
et en regardant le Grand Échiquier à la
télévision il vous inscrit vous votre
grande sœur et votre petit frère frère a
des cours de musique il se trouve que
votre frère Gautier et vous allez en
faire votre métier gautier Capuçon est
un très grand violencellliste vous un
très grand violoniste votre sœur a
préféré devenir orthophoniste autre iste
et votre carrière dans la musique tient
à peu de choses finalement à ce festival
des arcs oui ça tient à peu de choses ça
tient au fait que à peu de choses et
énormément de choses dans le sens où mes
parents ont eu cette cette envie surtout
ma mère de nous faire découvrir la
musique d'abord ma sœur puis moi et puis
mon frère ensuite ils ont dit découvert
eux même la musique dans ce festival des
ararts qui était par géographie pas loin
de chez eux c'était des concerts
gratuits et puis il y avait échancelle
Jacques Chancel qui est devenu ensuite
mon meilleur ami un de mes meilleurs
amis avec qui j'ai passé des heures à
parler jusqu'à jusqu'à son son départ
euh il découvrre le grand échiquet de
chancell et je pense que l'association
des deux ils vivent dans une petite
ville de province à Chambéry où il y a
un petit orchestre où il y a des
concerts il nous emmène et moi je je
tombe vraiment dans la marmite c'estàd
que immédiat
la musique devient à la fois un refuge
une façon de m'exprimer je pense que si
je fais un peu d'introspection sans
faire une psyanalyse à à TR sous j'étais
un gamin assez doué mais pas plus qu'un
autre mais extrêmement concentré j'avais
maintenant que je vois des des jeunes
des enfants et que j'ai eu moi-même un
fils ce que j'avais peut-être de
différent c'était la la capacité de
focus de de concentration qui m'a permis
d'aller plus vite et puis je savais où
j'allais et donc oui la chance d'avoir
des parents qui qui soutiennent qui
comprennent cette passion qui m'oblige
pas à faire des maths ou matp ou je ne
sais quoi ou de faire d'autres études
parce que il faut faire il faut pas être
musicien donc qui qui respecte le fait
qu'à 8 ans je décide d'être violoniste
et ils me disent ok banco oui parce que
c'est effectivement à l'âge de 7 8 ans
que vous dites à tout le monde que vous
voulez être violoniste alors qu'au
départ vous vouliez être skieur oui je
vou être skieur l'hiver et violoniste
l'été ce qui ce qui est un peu complexe
pas mal quand même et dès la 4e vous
partez à Paris vous êtes admis au
Conservatoire vous êtes le plus jeune de
votre classe le plus petit de taille
j'ai lu qu'on vous appelait Calimero
aussi ça m'a intrigué je me suis demandé
même si on si vous n'étiez pas moqué
alors on parle aujourd'hui de
harcèlement c'était cet ordre là alors
ouais c'est drôle c'est vous posez cette
question on était pour certains
clairement dans le harcèlement pas pour
Calimero ça c'était vraiment des potes
qui m'appelait comme ça c'était plutôt
sympathique c'est ceux qui me protégeent
d'ailleurs qui vous protégeait de qui
bah vous savez au Conservatoire j'avais
14 ans la plupart on avait 18 19 j'étais
vraiment le plus jeune cette année-là et
c'est facile de de de se moquer d'un
gamin 14 ans j'étais très à la fois très
en avance sur le côté violon et j'avais
14 ans donc j'étais un gamin qui venait
de la province et euh oui si j'ai je
c'est la première fois qu'on pose cette
question et si je me refais le le film
je revois une ou deux situations de oui
de harcèlement dans le sens de de
moquerie euh gratuite juste sur ma
taille mon âge et le fait que que
j'étais sans armes pour me défendre et
des humiliations euh que j'ai j'ai pas
oublié d'ailleurs h et quand vous
entendez aujourd'hui tout ce qui se dit
et ce qui se fait autour du harcèlement
ça vous touche vous avez été touché par
les discours que vous avez pu entendre
oui je pense que c'est essentiel parce
que c'est toujours la même chose ça peut
partir d'une blague d'une chose simple
mais enfin d'une chose simple d'une
chose qui qui qui semble rien pour ceux
qui sont harceleurs sauf si dans des cas
extrêmement vraiment grave mais très
souvent finalement on peut être même
dans une un groupe et être soi-même
harceleur sans s'en rendre compte je
pense que c'est très important de de que
les choses soient dites que les dans une
époque où je pense qu'on peut plus dire
les choses et on a une capacité
maintenant à avir les problèmes avec un
peu plus de recul que à l'époque
finalement quelqu'un qui qui sera aller
se plaindre d'une chose comme ça on se
serait moqué de lui oui à la lueur de
celui que vous êtes aujourd'hui quel
conseil donneriez-vous au petits garçons
ou au jeune ados qui va se lancer qui
s'apprête à se lancer dans la vie je le
fais avec mes élèves je le fais avec des
jeunes que je rencontre je leur dis dit
et surtout ne n'abandonnez jamais vos
rêves euh soyez extrêmement vigilant sur
le ce qui brille problème d'un musicien
c'est c'est un métier de de spectacle de
concert et vous avez euh autant de de
flatteurs et de gens qui vous disent
toute la journée que vous êtes géniaux
que enfin vous AZ beaucoup plus que des
gens qui vous remettent dans le droit
chemin d'accord donc euh de savoir euh
bien s'entourer bien s'entourer et et
surtout ne pas choisir le la facilité
pas choisir ce qui brille forcément
analyser les choses et euh et moi mon
rôle dans cette petite société que j'ai
créé qui s'appelle bossoir production
c'est justement de de conseiller les
jeunes et de leur éviter
des parfois des des chemins de traverse
qui pourrai les amener vraiment à des
catins ça arrive parfois que des jeunes
se perdent complètement parce que ils
ont un entourage qui leur passe qui
passe toute la journée à leur dire
qu'ils sont extraordinaires alors qu'ils
n'ont encore rien fait moi j'ai une
phrase très simple pour ces jeunes qui
parfois ont la tête qui gonfle un peu
trop vite et je leur dis tu sais en fait
c'est très simple on on est que des
interprètes donc le jour o on va donc je
m'adresser un jeune il y a pas longtemps
j'ai dit le jour où on disparaît en fait
toi comme moi au mieux on a deux lignes
dans un journal local national si
vraiment on est un peu plus connu la
maison de disque si elle est encore elle
existe encore au moment où on meurt elle
fait une petite compile et bastaosi
c'est fini et on disparaît mais
instantanément ça remet quand même les
choses donc ça les calme un peu moi j'ai
réalisé ça très tôt et et ça ça me donne
un regard comme ça sur les choses assez
simples et encore une fois quand on se
considère comme
artisan au service des musiciens
l'humilité elle est elle est essentielle
pourtant il vous est arrivé des choses
incroyables à 20 ans c'est une anecdote
que j'ai trouvé extraordinaire vous êtes
auditionné par Daniel barenby vous en
parliez tout à l'heure pianiste et chef
d'orchestre israello argentin pendant
l'audition il vous arrête et vous
demande de rejouer et il vous dit ceci
c'était tellement bien la première fois
que je voulais savoir si c'était le fait
du hasard ma secrétaire vous rappelle
demain pour aller à Chicago oui céit
drôle j'en ai reparlé il y a pas
longtemps on se parle très régulièrement
avec Daniel qui est un ami et je lui ai
rappelé cette anecdote et il a exploser
de rire en disant oui c'est c'est bien
mon genre et moi j'étais tétanisé parce
que c la prère j'avais 20 ans 19 ans à
Berlin dans une salle de l'Opéra je joue
pour Daniel baren bum il arrive entre
deux répétitions super pressé et cetera
il me dit je vous écoute je joue le
concer de B et il se passe cette chose
là je joue de deux pages il dit merci
beaucoup est-ce que vous pouvez
reprendre s'il vous plaît et dans ce
cas-là ça veut dire que oui ou c'est et
je pense qu'il voulait tester à la fois
mes Ners ma résistance physique euh de
voir ce que j'avais dans le ventre et et
voilà et on est devenu des amis depuis
mais c'est vrai que c'est un et comme
tout métier je mais là on se dit qu'on
est quand même à part non qu'on a un
talent non je pense que le jour où on se
dit qu'on est à part c'est là où tout
commence à à foirer non vraiment je
crois mais je vous crois vous avez l'air
je crois que
le bien sûr que c'est grisant de
rencontrer des gens extrêmement connu de
de d'avoir cette vie mais c'est pas les
paillettes c'est c'est le le le cœur du
réacteur c'est la musique et donc de
rencontrer baren Boy moabado ou julini
ou Martha rerich ce sont des gens qui
qui servent la musique et à leur contact
vous apprenez à être encore plus humble
parce qu'ils sont tellement hallucinants
que vous sentez tout petit en préparant
cette émission s aperçu que le classique
réunissait souvent des frattereries
c'est même assez troublant on a quelques
exemples Camille et Julie Bertolet
violon et violoncel Z zwani et sa sœur
fetoua chef d'orchestre et violenéliste
Katia et Marielle labeec pianiste toutes
les deux votre frère et vous c'est
étonnant quand vous vous l'expliquez
vous avez déjà réfléchi il y a
d'innombrables autres exemples bien sûr
c'est assez c'est assez étonnant et moi
j'aime cet exemple des sœurs Labe parce
que on les connaît depuis plus de 25 ans
maintenant sont des amis vraiment
proches et j'admire leur leur capacité à
avoir comme ça traversé les années en
étant toujours
train d'apprendre de chercher elle
commande des œuvres elle travaille des
heures et des heures pour moi c'est un
exemple incroyable et gotier et moi on a
beaucoup joué ensemble on a arrêté d'un
coup et donc forcément les gens
pensaient qu'on se faisait la gueule ce
qui était pas le cas simplement on a
arrêté d'un coup de jouer ensemble parce
qu'on ne voulait pas être assimilé au
fait d'être frère la grande différence
avec Katia et Mariel c'est que la bec
c'est que nous on est deux personnalités
qui jouont des carrières séparées Katia
Mariel ne jouent quasiment que ensemble
et on ne voulait pas avoir d'étiquettes
euh de frères uniquement bien sûr qu'on
est frères et qu'on rejouera ensemble
vous expliquez que souvent les
frattereries jouent enfin jouent bien et
et des carrières incroybles je pense que
c'est inhérant au fait
de d'abord d'un phénomène d'imitation
d'envie de de de la frattererie de jouer
ensemble peut-être qu'au début c'est
simplement les parents qui disent bah
toi tu joues Duon toi tu joues du Vion
je ne sais quoi et puis finalement ça se
ça se transforme en une une joie de de
un plaisir de jouer ensemble parce que
c'est quand même une des choses les plus
génial de la vie de jouer avec son frère
j'ai un document à vous proposer alors
vous inquiétez pas je vais vous le lire
et je vais je vais je vais préciser pour
No téléspectateurs pour ceux qui nous
écoutent c'est un document qui nous a
été transmis par nos partenaires les
Archives nationales je suis sûr qu'il va
vous plaire il s'agit du testament de
Jean-Auguste Dominique ingre immense
peintre du 19e siècle mais aussi
enseignant sénateur et violoniste il a
même été 2uxe violon à l'Orchestre du
Capitol de Toulouse et de ce loisir est
né l'expression violon d'ingre dans ce
testament que vous avez là sous les yeux
il lue son violon à sa ville natale
est-ce que vous vous savez déjà ce que
vous ferez de vos violons est-ce que
voulez lesgé ah ben le violon que j'ai
toujours pas fini de payer il faut déjà
donc il faudrait déjà que j'arrive à
terminer de le payer ça va prendre
encore un certain nombre d'années et le
jour où il sera enfin à moi j'espère que
je serai pas trop vieux mais je me suis
pas encore vraiment posé la question
mais je pense que je ligrai à ma famille
euh et sauf si je dois le le le vendre
pour X raison et dans ce cas-là se
posera évidemment la question de le
vendre moi je préférais 1000 fois le
vendre à un musicien qu'àun investisseur
ou qu'un h qu'est-ce qui représente le
violon pour vous c'est c'est un
partenaire c'est un doudou c'est
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
euh un partenaire oui mais c'est le
c'est la ma façon de m'exprimer même si
aujourd'hui je dirige aussi je n'ai pas
mon violon et j'arrive à m'exprimer
aussi mais est-ce qu'on le personnifie
est-ce qu'on en fait presque un être à
partentière est-ce que on dort à côté
enfin je veux dire qu'est-ce que il est
pas très loin il pas très loin de moi
euh pour des raisons de sécurité et des
raisons aussi un peu oui vous avez dit
doudou c'est drôle j'ai m pensé mais
c'est un peu ça il y a il y a on est
rassuré au-delà de ça je m'exprime avec
cet instrument depuis plus de 20 ans
maintenant et depuis avec le violon
depuis 44 ans parce que j'ai commencé à
4 ans ça fait quand même vous provenez
sans violon là vous êtes venus sans par
exemple ouais vous arrivez à vous en
séparer sa je suis assez normal il se
dit que lors d'un déjeuner en présence
de Jacques shirac vous auriez demandé à
l'ancien président de bien vouloir se
laver les mains avant de toucher votre
violon vous auriez même jeté un froid
que shirac a lui-même brisé en éclatant
de rire et en en allant effectivement se
laver les mains avant de toucher viol
exactement ça non non c'est absolument
vrai c'it un déjeuner en Savoie avec des
skilleurs des champions de ski et un
violoniste et il voulait voir le violon
le président et donc je prends le violon
il tend ses mains et comme on venait de
manger du fromage je lu demandé
simplement de donc il s'est essuyé les
mains et c'est vrai que ça a jeté un
froid absolument incroyable on a je
pense que tous les skieurs on pensais
que j'étais d'une d'une arrogance totale
mais je l'ai fait avec beaucoup de
respect et Chirac a été génial parce que
il RPU mais vous n'imaginez pas c'est un
instrument extrêmement précieux et mon
ami Étienne battl et et finalement ça a
détendu totalement d'atmosphère il vous
a complètement compris en fait il a com
votre rapport à ce violon j'ai des
photos à vous proposer ça fait partie
des rituels de cette
émission voici la première c'est
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous partagez votre vie avec
elle la journaliste Laurence Ferrari
est-ce que c'est vrai que vous ne
l'aviez jamais vu à l'écran lorsque vous
la renc vous ne l'aviez vous ne la
connaissiez pas pour vous dire vraiment
la les choses comme se sont passé j'ai
été invité à un dîner chez Michel
Barnier qui qui était ministre de
l'agriculture où elle était aussi
invitée et j'avais décidé de ne pas
aller à ce déjeuner à ce dîner parce que
j'étais vraiment fatigué super fatigué
et donc j'ai demandé la liste des
invités et j'ai dû googler son nom j'ai
vu sa photo et j'ai confirmé le dîner
voilà c'est exactement comme ça que ça
s'est passé donc vous étiez quand même
vraiment dans une bulle j'étais vraiment
dans une bulle on d'accord je parlais
d'entourage compréhensif elle doit être
compréhensive pour le violon qu'elle
entend tous les jour moi aussi je suis
compréhensive par vivre avec une
journaliste oui mais le le son du violon
tous les jours ça doit pas être alors
d'abord elle a la chance que je voyage
beaucoup donc je suis pas tous les jours
là c'est vrai que quand je travaille
comme au mois de décembre le concer
Schenberg 7h par jourou même les voisins
qui adorent quand je joue se sont
demandé quand ça allait s'arrêter
j'avoue et je m'excuse auprès d'eux mais
de façon générale je travaille avec la
sourdine en plomb donc on entend très
peu et je joue quand même plus des
choses audibles que inaudibles bon ça va
alors une dernière fois Pho il s'agit du
musicien rostropovic dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure devant le Mur de Berlin
avec son violon cel le 11 novembre 1989
pour célébrer à sa façon la chute du mur
de Berlin improvisant un récital dans
ces périodes historiques troublé est-ce
que vous diriez que la musique classique
et peut-être le violon peut jouer un
rôle politique d'apaisement c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure je pense que la
musique le violon ou un autre instrument
s'il est
porté moi je suis artiste pour la paix
au sein de l'UNESCO et je suis très
heureux et très fier de ce titre qui qui
est une chose qui me me pousse à
utiliser l'art pour ça mes modèles comme
je l'ai dit c'est terostropovit c'est
Menin c'est baren boy aujourd'hui la
musique peut être un moyen absolument
incroyable puisque sans mot et sans
nationalité on peut avoir des concerts
aujourd'hui où un Ukrainien peut jouer à
côté d'un russe à côté d'un Israélien à
côté d'un Palestinien vous aez envie de
jouer quelque part là en ce moment pour
symboliser la paix justement avec votre
instrument j'aimerais jouer dans si
c'est s'il était possible de me
téléporter dans toutes les zones de
guerre aujourd'hui je le ferais c'est
vous imaginez beaucoup plus complexe que
l'on veut bien le penser mais je suis
très souvent j'ai des espèces d'élan et
j'ai la chance d'avoir une femme qui est
journaliste et donc qui peut me
conseiller sur ces choses là et la
plupart du temps il me dit c'est une
formidable attention mais tu peux pas
faire ça et je pense que il faut aussi
se se méfier de de de pas être comme
tout d'un coup oui oui qui va dans
chaque pays et cetera donc il faut avoir
avoir juste place la juste place et et
de pas dénaturer non plus cette mission
d'une certaine façon d'ambassadeur de de
de la musique auprès de ces de ces
populations et mais je pense vraiment
que on peut grâce à la musique faire
passer d'innombrables message et que les
politiques devraient utiliser beaucoup
plus comme arme diplomatique la musique
de façon générale l'appel est lancé une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
le lieu dans lequel nous sommes Ren
capuon nous sommes entourés de quatre
statutes qui représentent chacune une
vertu il y a il y a la sagesse la
prudence la justice et l'éloquence
laquelle de ces vertus vous parle le
plus ou vous caractérise vous peut-être
non je pense que elle me parle toutes la
justice l'éloquence dites-moi les deux
sagesse prudence prudence sagesse
prudence ça c'est vraiment ce que
j'essaie de de faire passer aux jeunes
je pense que c'est une chose qui qui est
extrêmement important en tout cas si on
veut durer sur le long terme si on veut
simplement être une star et durer 3 ans
alors ils ont pas besoin de mes conseils
et donc pour dan sagesse et éloquence je
pense que en musique l'éloquence fait
partie de la rhétorique merci Rena cap
d'avoir été avec nous dans cette
émission merci d'avoir partagé ce beau
moment et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi comme chaque semaine et je
rappelle que vous êtes à l'Olympia le 10
mars prochain merci Ren à très
[Musique]
bientôt